what is up welcome back
to the 10 million dollar studio i know
it seems like we're changing all the
time but
actually we are just moving within the
same room we're trying different ways of
organizing the set to make it easier for
you guys
um this is doubling right now as a
screen but actually look at this
i can turn it off boom boom there's our
board huh
not too shabby and as you can see moved
into a new place there's an annoying guy
next door he's kind of snooping around
which is kind of annoying
ben cumberbund or something like that i
don't know what his name is he's always
trailed by his bumbling sidekick
i don't know what it's about because
they're kind of weird i don't know what
their deal is
but nevertheless we're not going to let
that stop us it's some good real estate
for finding out the new mysteries of the
internet from digging up the scams from
exposing the frauds
so thank you for joining me on this
journey now
today we are reacting to fake gurus
calling out fake gurus let me say
i'm having trouble here seeing my future
because i just invested in a 10 million
dollar studio to call out fake gurus
and i'm gonna be out of a job soon
because i can't
call out the fake gurus faster than the
fake gurus are calling out the fake
gurus you won't believe it i never
thought in a million years
that the strategy of a fake guru would
be
to call out fake gurus i don't know what
the idea there is
like do they not think we'll see through
it let's find out here's a few that i
collected today for us to look at
together
so this is our first guy and i'm just
going to say here i see this not as a
video but as
actually an ad this guy's spending money
to call out fake gurus it's insane
oh this another online business guru i
don't know about you but i'm getting
pretty sick and
tired of all of these fake online
business damn boy
business gurus trying to get me to this
guy watches coffeezilla
for sure 100 you register for their
webinars guys i know you've been seeing
the ad but i promise you if you just
give me 60 seconds
okay so then you give him 60 seconds
right you're gonna give him 60 seconds
and you think
oh man he's not going to be like them
right if you want to create a life of
better financial freedom live the life
of your dreams and stop working a
nine-to-five job stop doing all the
stuff that you hate
click the link around this video
sorry we already went on to the next one
oops you guys have been spoiled but
let me just say that i'll just say i
just what just one word about that last
guy
dude you can't call out the gurus and
then sell your webinar go sell your free
training
bro come to my free training put my free
training where i saw you on my course
what a joke are more scams out there on
the internet
than there are legitimate opportunities
by
far okay let's check out this
[Music]
cut to john crostati selling scams
listen let me say let me say this
about uh let me say this about that
thing because i talked to john christani
i said how much did it cost to get chris
hanson on your show he said 25k
25k to
call out the gurus now this itself was a
scam because you were supposed to buy a
book which is a 20
a month upsell for the book a book that
cost
has a 20 a month subscription attached
to it
but yeah john you just keep calling out
the the scammers buddy
okay let's check out this method to
literally copy paste ads to make money
first off you don't want to run a
business where you have to actually like
buy products and like ship them out to
people okay
so let's forget about e-commerce or drop
shipping i don't even know why i tried
it these guys
make such better comedy than i ever
could with these things
there are so many scams out there but
make bank they do we're gonna make bank
sell my product work for it search for
my last name because the product we're
gonna be
the products we're gonna be selling it's
actually my product selling is actually
my product unfortunately
all right next meme i don't know that's
pewdiepie right no never mind
uh next guru only the world of ecommerce
education
is full of scammers pretenders okay hold
on i want to pause there because it's
going to be funny later
he's saying that the baller busters are
calling out the scammers okay remember
that
outright liars i'm sure you've seen
their ads all over the place
and i bet many of you have even been
their victims
for all of you gurus and self-reclaimed
experts out there
you better watch group beware
now when you go to ballerbuster's page
remember this is the guy that's calling
out the gurus the kevin zhang endorses
kevin zang is one of their callers dude
what the [ __ ]
is there i am going back to the show
guys a little uh little
little collab with ballerbusters but
this is
a long call out oh look he's doing
another e-commerce
70 off that was the scam he did last
time where am i headed
from jail next guru
the stock market can be a very dangerous
place if you're following
a fake if you're learning from a fake
and because of this bull market there
are lots of fakes
in this video i'm going to talk about it
and tell you how to expose
a fake ah yes tim sykes the original
huckster dude
yes so this video which is uh released
recently called like calling out gurus
or how to spot a fake guru
it's all just him pitching his million
dollar challenge if you want to get into
my millionaire challenge and you're
ready
to be you know taught by a drill
sergeant now one of my favorite things
about tim sykes the millionaire trader
is that uh he's got verified trades on a
platform called
profit.ly or profitly
now here's an interesting thing who
verified tim sykes trades well
profitably but who owns profitly tim's
hikes
that's right tim sykes has verified tim
sykes trades you better not call him a
scam dude
hey they're verified verified by him
okay next guru
i see one more person on my tick tock
timeline oh professional advice because
danny devin thousands and sometimes even
millions of dollars in their robin hood
account i swear i'm gonna rip out my
hair
okay you can't you shouldn't be able to
teach if you just have a thousand or a
million dollars in your account you're
saying
don't fall for all these fake robin hood
gurus okay so don't trust somebody just
because they say they have millions of
dollars in their stock market account
got it i made a million dollars in four
weeks and this is exactly how i did it
this is by the way like several months
later after he calls out the gurus
oh don't listen all those other idiot
gurus hey by the way i made millions of
dollars
start off with a thousand dollars which
i turned into five thousand five
thousand to ten thousand
ten thousand to twenty five thousand
twenty five thousand to fifty thousand
and wouldn't you believe it fifty
thousand into a million dollars hey
and this is definitely not a demo
account not a demo account but i turned
a thousand dollars into a million
dollars totally uh yeah this is
very believable yeah just no big deal
100 000
returns that's it hey hundred thousand
percent returns what are you gonna say
i'm lying
next scammer mindset if you're doing
that and you're trying to scam people
you don't have to go down that path this
is a tick-tock person named
lovin not working but what does she say
scammers need right mindset that's right
if you're scamming you got the wrong
mindset stay honest stay true to
yourself
you'll live a happier life you'll be
able to sleep better at night the good
news is you could change but
unfortunately
you know that's a you decision oh okay
so yeah all you fake gurus out there
all you scammers do the right thing
don't you know stop scamming people
i want to show you how to get from a
thousand dollars to a million dollars
and check out the link in my bio for
more
oh a little course action there
little two percent theory yeah just a
thousand dollars to a million dollars
two years what's the big deal just
trading crypto baby
all right and that's basically it yeah i
don't know what i'm gonna do here on
this channel
all the gurus are calling out all the
gurus i don't really know what to do
they're all saying
watch out for the fake gurus as fake
gurus i honestly don't know where my
place is anymore i'm lost i'm confused
let me know what you think guys what do
you think let me know what you think of
the studio too guys we're slowly
we're building out our 10 million dollar
set we're paying off
the loan um it's a massive loan so if
you haven't already go
buy my fake guru spotter course for the
low low price of 10 million dollars
or 69 million dollars if you get the
flash sale which i'm only doing
one time which is this very second and
the first 500 people to click the link
below
and uh that's basically it and don't
forget to smash like
and subscribe thank you